[Music]
did you know there was a college
Christmas party tonight NFI me and you
not
invited you all right yeah I've got a
flat tire take my bike hey that is so
kind thank you I'm sorry I don't know
your name I'm I'm Felix Oliver Oliver
Oliver I love you I love I love you
right cheers
Olie my parents they've got problems
what kind of what do you mean problems I
don't think I'll ever go home again well
why don't you come home with me come to
salurn Mr Quick wow and here he is now
oh what beautiful eyes oh how wonderful
yeah I told you it wasn't a minger oh
but darling you're kind about everyone
you can't be
trusted I had them hang up an old school
dinner jacket we dressed for dinner here
dress for dinner yeah it's like was like
black
tie I think I like even more than last
year's
one you're so um so what
real can't of being easy for Venicia
like you being a mother
why now it's time to take things up a
not sh had them Apple Bottom Jeans boots
with the
fur
this
place you know it's not for
you lots of people get lost in
salurn well that's just give me
goosebumps look Pamela oh
no I think you're a
mar quiet harmless drawn to shiny things
what have you doing I just thought that
maybe I could help you're not leaving us
you're not leaving
S I don't think I'll ever go home
[Music]
[Applause]
again
[Music]